wer seine eltern ärgern möchte der
sollte sich dieses video genauer
anschauen denn heute erkläre ich euch
warum wir nachweislich intelligenter
sind als unsere eltern
[Musik]
der moderne mensch macht gerade eine
seltsame evolution seit beginn des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts wird er fort
gehend schlauer
die werte professionell durchgeführten
test steigt aktuell tatsächlich um etwa
0 3 punkte pro jahr
kinder übertreffen ihre eltern im
schnitt um zehn punkte im gut ist dieses
phänomen nennt man den flynn effekt
benannt nach dem politologen james blind
und die tests werden von experten als
eines der besten diagnostischen
instrumenten der psychologie angesehen
auf deren ergebnisse man sich verlassen
kann vorausgesetzt sie werden fachkundig
ausgeführt und ausgewertet werden die
tests also stimmen woher kommt das
stetige steigen des iq sowohl das klären
müssen wir kurz festhalten was der iq
eigentlich ist der intelligenz quotient
ist kein absoluter wird sondern immer
ein bezugswert im vergleich zur
gesamtbevölkerung so sieht die iq
verteilung immer aus einem glockenkurve
wir haben es hier mit einer sogenannten
normalverteilung tut der großer der
menschen in der mitte und die ist per
definition 100 nur sehr wenige menschen
knapp 25 prozent sind entweder
hochbrücke abspricht und größere 130
oder geistig behindert sprich ihre
kleider 70 deswegen muss die justierung
der inku beteilung ständig neu
vorgenommen werden aber da die
verteilung an sich immer gleich aussieht
hat es der zeit lang gedauert bis james
flint die seltsame entdeckung machte
nämlich dass eine kuh von 100 heute viel
höher liegt als eine kuh von 100 im
jahre 1900 im vergleich zu der
menschheit 1900 hätten wir nach
damaligem standard ein durchschnitts iq
von 130 wir werden also damals alle
hochbegabt gewesen bzw die menschen
derzeit hätten nach heutigem standard
ein durchschnitts iq von 70 das heißt
sie wären im schnitt geistig behindert
ich kann das sein
naja gebräuchliche intelligenztests
bestehen aus verschiedenen segmenten wo
verschiedene skills getestet werden und
nicht in allen segmenten verbessern sich
die menschen stetig in den kategorien
rechner oder wortschatz bleiben die
ergebnisse über die generation ziemlich
konstant die stetige verbesserung des
gesamtergebnisses ist fast
ausschließlich auf ganz bestimmte teile
des iq tests zurück
für die auf diese drei cs-aktien nämlich
erstens klassifizierung so halten es
abstraktes denken und drittens
hypothetisches ding schauen wir uns mal
an was das alles genau bedeutet die
fähigkeit zur klassifizierung taucht in
intelligenztests in etwa so auf was
haben äpfel und orangen gemeinsam der
psychologe alexander lyria führte in den
20er jahren sehr interessante
befragungen mit russischen bauern durch
er fragte sie zum beispiel was haben wir
eigentlich und eine gemeinsame heute
würden wir zumindest mal sagen es sind
beides tiere aber für die menschen
damals hat einen fisch und krähen über
nichts gemeinsam
weil die menschen vor nicht allzu langer
zeit noch ganz anders gedacht haben
früher bezog man seinem denken die
gegenstände umwelt immer auf sich und
den konkreten nutzen für ein selbst bei
fischen dachten die bauern nebenan tiere
die man fangen und essen kann bei krähen
dachten sie anwesen mit denen man dass
menschen überhaupt bis anfang an die
bauern waren nicht unbedingt dünner
sondern nur extrem pragmatisch wenn man
so wild doch dieses nutzen bezogene
denken hat sich im laufe des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts stark gewandelt die zweite
wichtige sache abstraktes denken davon
verlangt die moderne welt immer mehr
unsere omas und opas haben zum beispiel
ein problem damit dass knöpfe heutzutage
gar keine mechanischen knöpfel mehr sein
müssen sondern vielleicht nur ein icon
auf dem schirm einen digital native
hingegen ist es völlig klar dass es
irgendeine art von an und aus knopf
geben muss der aber von gerät zu gerät
völlig verschiedene aussehen kann auch
die bildung hat sich verändert schaut
man sich amerikanische schultests an aus
dem jahre 1910 da gab es also fragen wie
was ist die hauptstadt von ohio 1990
sehen wie fragen schon ganz anders aus
zum beispiel warum ist die größte stadt
eines staates selten die hauptstadt
scheint eleganz test prüfen auch ob die
man dazu in der lage ist logische
analogien zu ziehen zum beispiel dessen
wert sich zu hungrig wie trinken zu
durstig
wie sie richtig im jahr 1900 war das
auch noch wie sie jetzt werden wir ein
bisschen abstrakt anschaulich die
sitzreihen an wenn ihr die zweite reihe
logisch und analog zur ersten reihe
verenden listet was müsste dann dastehen
richtig ein halbkreis denn ein dreieck
ist ein halbes quadrat und an
das ist ein halber greifen während die
leute 1900 noch probleme mit dieser
aufgabe hatten war es 1960 kein problem
mehr
eden games jahres 2010 wir werden noch
abstrakt wir haben jetzt hier kreis
kreis halbkreis und ruder steht 16 16
fragezeichen die meisten college
studenten sitzen hier richtig 818 ist
die hälfte von 16 und ein halbkreis ist
die elfte von einem kreis 1960 hätten
die meisten damit noch probleme gehabt
was uns heute also leichter fällt als
früher ist auf einem ganz abstrakten
level zwischenformen und zahlen logik
anzuwenden kommen wir zum letzten
wichtigen skill impfen effekt
hypothetisches denken gehen wir zurück
zur jurierung seiner befragung der
russischen bauern er sagte zu ihnen da
wo immer schnee liegt sind wären immer
was am nordpol nicht immer schnee welche
farben gebären dort die bauern mussten
damals überhaupt nichts mit dieser
hypothetischen frage anzufangen sie
antworteten einfach sie hätten doch nie
etwas anderes als einen braunbären
gesehen das hat aber nichts mit dummheit
zu tun
sie waren durchaus in der lage logisch
zu denken sie war nur nicht bereit
logisches denken auf hypothetische
fragestellungen anzuwenden wenn ich
heute sage wo es immer bonbons regnen
die fähren immer blau gestreifter
kartoffel anträge des immer bonbons
welche fahren haben die bären dort dann
würde jeder sagen logisch blau gestreift
so wie wir heute denken steht die logik
im vordergrund damit dass es keine
bonbons redet und dass es keine
gestreiften bären gibt damit haben wir
heute überhaupt kein problem wären wenn
jemand glaubt ist die russischen bauern
dumm sind mit ihrer beschränkten auf die
frauen werden
so was passiert heute immer noch gar
nicht allzu langer zeit habe ich ein
video gemacht über autonomes fahren und
moralischen dilemmas zum beispiel wenn
ein selbst fahrendes auto in die
situation käme dass es entweder ein
kleines kind oder eine ober umfahren
müsste und auch noch technisch dazu in
der lage wäre zwischen dem kleinkind
unter ober zu unterscheiden wie sollte
es programmiert sein
in wen sollte es reinfahren und ganz
viele der kommentare waren so was gibt
es ist eine total dumme frage war es zu
genau dieser situation niemals kommen
würde es geht also gar nicht darum wer
schlau oder weniger schlaf ist sondern
wer mehr oder weniger dazu bereit ist
hypothetische wenn auch unrealistische
oder absurde situation trotzdem logisch
durchzudenken ich möchte an dieser
stelle auf dem tech talk von james king
himself verweisen wo er selbst über
seine entdeckungen spricht habe ich euch
und verlinkt er spricht unter anderem
über die 60er jahre wo er student war
über martin luther king und darüber wie
er mit seinem großvater in streit geriet
welcher der meinung war dass schwarze
menschen eher minderwertig sind oder
sagt es ihm
was würdest du machen wenn du morgen
aufwachen würdest und festlich
schwarzwerte sein großvater sagte das
ist die dümmste frage die ich je gehört
habe
er konnte nichts damit anfangen weil es
ja nicht passieren würde wir sehen also
dass die bereitschaft zum logischen
durchdenken von hypothetischen situation
gerade für moralisch und
gesellschaftliche debatten richtig ist
das heißt aber gleichzeitig auch das
gesellschaftliche debatten heutzutage
viel schneller eskalieren weil uns das
was wäre wenn so wichtig geworden ist
aber wären wir nicht dazu bereit
hypothesen ernst zu nehmen selbst wenn
sie nicht möglich sind werden wir nicht
dazu bereit uns um das was wäre wenn
gedanken zu machen das ganz pragmatisch
um das was ist würden wir uns viel
langsamer weiterentwickeln forschung und
wissenschaft sind nichts anderes als
hypothesen aufzustellen und den mit
logik nachzugehen hoch intelligente
menschen wie zb damast sind oft spinner
weil sie spaß am hypothetischen am von
möglichen haben weswegen er zum beispiel
gerade versucht den markt zu besiedeln
also werden immer schlauer auf dem
papier unsere iq werte steigen steht das
ist alles aber nur auf diese drei skills
zurückzuführen klassifizierung
abstraktes denken und hypothetisches
denken experten glauben dass der film
effekt noch lange nicht vorbei ist und
zumindest noch dieses jahr 100
weiterlaufen wird das heißt es auch wir
unseren kindern und enkelkindern
irgendwann nicht mehr folgen
letztendlich zeigt uns der flynn effekt
dass intelligenz viel komplizierter ist
eine zahl aus einem iq-test und manchmal
wünsche ich mir sogar den pragmatismus
unserer vorfahren ein bisschen zurück
der am ende ist es am wichtigsten was
wir mit unserer intelligenz anstellen
lassen eure gedanken zum flynn effekt
schreibt sie in die kommentare zusammen
mit euren fragen hier auch mal gern in
einem video beantwortet hättet wir sehen
uns nächste woche sein plötzlicher